my wife knows where my heart is and and
where I'm at and she knows I have this
void
to be famous and be known and she she
knows me and she's known me my whole
life uh What attracted her to me when I
met her was I was actually really good
looking one so I had that John Travolta
look with her and I was funny she said
that's why I liked you wait so she like
you just really me because I was myself
I say let I know you're Chinese and
sometimes you're on your knees well
we'll talk about that another time and
she's from Jacqueline Hawaii from the
island of I like a Dickie
but that's the [__] that's the [__] that
she loves she likes that [__] she won't
say she does but I is English your first
language Lynn she was born here but I'm
going to tell you a funny story her
father is a very big business guy
and he's very serious and she said you
are the only person ever that got my dad
to laugh how did you get him to laugh
because I'm funny no but what did you
say do you remember oh I don't remember
but even Lynch about her's daughter did
you say that stuff I wouldn't do Chinese
jokes she's not be disowned but I but
you're doing them now will he not hear
them I think he thinks this is just
between us this is just between us does
he is he alive yeah he's 90 now but
here's the thing Jacqueline I got a guy
who's a very
affluent businessman in Hong Kong who
ran a company for 30 years real estate
company serious he doesn't talk when we
eat he's the nicest person
very quiet no he talks he's quiet he
listens a lot and I got him to laugh and
nobody gets Lynn's dad to laugh so I
feel that I just felt so good I could do
that like that made me feel really good
so you said you said Lynn is very quiet
and he's reserved she's so she would
talk and be not while they're eating
guys yeah she would talk to the dad's
very quiet the mom likes to talk but
Asian people they're different than
America people okay the little reserves
are quiet not all Asian people well the
family I married
[Music]